in today's eight on your side want to  jump start your holiday savings or  save for vacation well selling your old  items can help with that and you don't  have to be an expert at sales to make  money this way  henderson mom of two tara clarkson uses  a number of different apps like  offer up and let go which combined  marketplaces over the summer  there's henderson's swap and shop and  for only brand name items henderson  higher end yard sale you don't have to  go to the store and pay top dollar for  these things  that's for sure coming up at five we'll  show you how simple it is to post an  item yourself  and share some other websites with you  as well